hi everyone this is professor omdar
science and today i want to talk about
the radial equation of central
potentials
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics a central potential is
a potential that only depends on the
distance from the origin today we're
going to see
that the wave function of a particle
that is moving
in a central potential can be divided
into two parts
the first part is the angular part which
is fully determined by the
eigenfunctions of the orbital angular
momentum
so you can learn all about it in our
series of videos on orbital angular
momentum the second
is the radial part and that is the topic
of this video we will derive the
equation obeyed by the radial part and
we will find that
unlike the angular part it depends on
the specific form of the potential you
can then find solutions for particular
potentials for example the isotropic
harmonic oscillator
or the hydrogen atom in the videos that
are linked in the description and today
we will also introduce the concept
of an effective potential which goes far
beyond
central potentials so let's go let's
start with a quick refresher on
central potentials we typically work in
the position representation using
spherical coordinates
and in this language the central
potential is a potential
that only depends on the distance from
the origin so it only depends
on the scalar r put it another way
essential potential is invariant under
any rotation about the origin
the hamiltonian of a particle moving in
a general potential
has a kinetic energy term and a
potential
energy term in the companion video on
central potentials we find that we can
rewrite this hamiltonian in the position
representation
and in terms of spherical coordinates
using this very long expression
to do this for the kinetic energy term
we essentially have to write the
laplacian
in spherical coordinates and after some
manipulations we found that it can be
divided into two parts
this first term that depends on
derivatives with respect to
the radial variable and this second term
that involves the square orbital angular
momentum operator
the angular dependence of the
hamiltonian is entirely captured by
this operator here and all other terms
only depend on the radial variable
this expression for the hamiltonian
suggests that angular momentum plays a
key role
in central potentials and indeed we
found in the corresponding video that
angular momentum is a constant of motion
we also found that l squared commutes
with the hamiltonian
and so does lz
then we can use h l squared and lz as a
set of compatible observables on which
we develop the quantum theory of central
potentials
this implies that eigenfunctions of a
particle moving in a central potential
can be chosen to simultaneously obey the
eigenvalue equation of the hamiltonian
the eigenvalue equation of the square
orbital angular momentum
and the eigenvalue equation of the lz
component of orbital angular momentum
when working with central potentials we
are therefore looking for the
simultaneous solution
of these three equations but
from our series on orbital angular
momentum we already know the solution of
the two
angular momentum equations and indeed
i've already used
this knowledge to write down the allowed
eigenvalues of l squared
here in terms of the quantum number l
and of lz here in terms of the quantum
number
ml this means that all we really need to
do
is to solve the eigenvalue equation for
the hamiltonian
to do so we start by writing out the
eigenvalue equation for the hamiltonian
in spherical coordinates
first we have the hamiltonian and i'm
using the expression that we discussed
in the previous slide it acts on the
eigenfunction
and this is equal to the eigenvalue
times the eigenfunction again
let's first focus on the middle term
here that depends on l squared
writing it down we then act
with it on the eigenfunction
and using the eigenvalue equation of
l-squared here
we end up with this term
this means that we can rewrite the
eigenvalue equation of the hamiltonian
using this new expression
for the hamiltonian acting on the
eigenfunction
and all of this is equal to the
eigenvalue
times the same eigenfunction
so this is the latest expression we got
for the eigenvalue equation on the
hamiltonian
we're now going to use another result
from the videos on orbital angular
momentum
the eigenfunction psi of r can be
separated into a radial part
and an angular part the angular part
here
is given by a family of functions called
spherical harmonics
which are simultaneous eigenfunctions of
l squared and lz
these spherical harmonics are completely
determined by the angular momentum
eigenvalue equations
and all that is left to determine is the
radial part
this is precisely what we're trying to
do today we will explore
how the eigenvalue equation for the
hamiltonian allows us to determine the
rail part right here
we can plug in this expression into the
eigenvalue equation for the hamiltonian
and we get the hamiltonian
the separated eigenfunction
all equal to the eigenvalue times the
eigenfunction again
the hamiltonian here has no angular
dependence
this means that the angular part of the
eigenfunctions appear
only as multiplicative factors so we can
divide
through by the spherical harmonics here
and here
the final equation only depends on the
radial variable
and for obvious reasons it is called the
radial equation
and all we have left to do is to solve
it
now spoiler we're actually not going to
solve
the radial equation today because its
solution depends on the precise form
of the central potential here what this
means is that the radial function will
depend on the specific potential that we
have
for example it'll be different for a
hydrogen atom compared to
an isotropic harmonic oscillator as a
result we'll have to solve this radial
equation separately
for every central potential of interest
and you can find the solution for a
range of central potentials in the
videos that are linked in the
description
what i want to do today is to explore
some of the properties
of the radial equation that are general
in the sense that they don't really
depend on the specific form
of the central potential this will
prepare us to then be able to solve
specific
central potential problems
the first thing i want to discuss are
quantum numbers
the rail equation depends on the angular
momentum quantum number
l and i will therefore define a new
operator hl
as equal to this
this operator hl is simply the
hamiltonian of the system
for a given l but we actually have an
infinite number of different hl
hamiltonians
because i can take any non-negative
integer value
this means that we actually have an
infinite number of radial equations
as every possible value of l leads to a
different hamiltonian
hl we can therefore rewrite our radial
eigenvalue equation as this family of
equations
one for every l the eigenfunctions
are and the eigenvalues e are now
labeled by the index
l here here and here
because in general they will be
different for every different date chill
hamiltonian
for a given hamiltonian hl we will also
have the usual spectrum of eigenvalues
and eigenfunctions
and i'm using the index k here here
and here to label the energy spectrum
for a given hl hamiltonian
overall the eigenvalues and eigenstates
of the radial equation
are labeled by the indices k and l
interestingly ml which is the angular
momentum quantum number associated with
the z
component of orbital angular momentum
doesn't feature
in the radial equation this means that
our eigenvalues and eigenfunctions
do not depend on ml
however as for every possible value of l
there are two l plus one different ml
values
then this also means that e kl is at
least
2l plus 1 fold degenerate
the next thing i want to do is to
simplify the radial equation
by making a change of variables let
rkl of r be equal to 1 over r
times ukl of r if we look at the
differential operator here
then we can consider its action on the
radial function which i'm already
spelling out in terms of
u this r cancels with this 1 over r
and we get this
this means that we can rewrite the
radial equation in terms of the u
function
like this where i'm taking a common
factor of 1 over r
outside the bracket
the 1 over r cancel here and
here and we end up with this
new radial equation for you
next we're going to find a constraint on
the function u
by studying the behavior of the
potential in the limit r going to zero
to do so we're going to make an
assumption about the form
of the potential we will assume
that the potential is well behaved as it
approaches the origin
in the sense that it does not diverge
too fast
in particular we're going to assume that
the limit as r approaches zero
of r squared times v or r is equal to
zero
this essentially means that the
potential does not approach
0 faster than 1 over r
while this assumption in printable means
that we are losing some generality
in practice this regime is true in
physically relevant potentials
most importantly the coulomb potential
so we're just going to proceed with this
next we're going to consider what the
radial equation up here
looks like in this limit of r
approaching the origin
let's write the limit of the various
terms that do not include at derivative
and under our assumption the fastest the
potential v
can vary goes like 1 over r
so as r approaches the origin the
dominant term is
this one as it goes like 1 over r
squared
this means that the limit reduces to
this single term
now you may have noticed that this is
not quite the full story because
in the l equals zero case this term
vanishes however the results that we
will get
turn out to also be valid for l equals
zero
overall this means that we can rewrite
the regular equation in the limit that r
approaches the origin
with just the derivative term and
the l dependent term acting on the u
function
this prefactor now cancels with this one
here
and here and rearranging we end up with
the derivative term
equal to this
this is now a simple second-order
differential equation for you
and the general strategy is to try a
solution of the form
r to the power alpha plugging this trial
solution the left hand side is the
second derivative which gives
alpha times alpha minus 1 times r to the
power
alpha minus two and the right hand side
gives
l times l plus one times r to the alpha
minus two
the r terms cancel here and here and the
equation simplifies to a relation
between
alpha and l there are two solutions
the first corresponds to alpha equal to
l plus one
and the second to alpha equals minus
l in turn this means that we have two
linearly
independent solutions for the radial
equation in the limit
of r going to zero the first is u
proportional to
r to the power l plus one
and the second u proportional to r to
the power
minus l
remembering that the original radial
function r
is related to u by this equation
then the corresponding solutions for r
are this one
and this one
now it turns out that this second
solution is in fact
not possible to see this we can go all
the way to our original eigenvalue
equation in terms of laplacian
with the central potential and the
original eigenfunction psi
with this solution we would get a psi
that looks like this
in the limit of r going to zero but the
laplacian of a function like this
involves the lth derivative of the delta
function
this means that the left hand side here
could
never equal this right hand side here
the reason we got this impossible
solution near the origin
is rather subtle it is a result of the
fact
that when we wrote the laplacian in
spherical coordinates
the expression that we wrote is actually
only valid for r
different than zero
overall the main conclusion for us is
that the only valid solution in the
limit that r tends to zero is this one
for you
or equivalently this one for r
to enforce the solution we can transform
it into the constraint
that u k l at the origin must be zero
and in this way we remove the second
solution which does
not go to zero at the origin
as a final point before we move on you
will remember that at the beginning of
this derivation
when we took the limit for r going to
zero we ended up with an
expression that was only valid for l
larger than
zero now that we have this conclusion
you can easily check that it applies
generally by directly considering the
equation
with l equals zero
another important point is normalization
in general the full wave function psi of
the system should be normalized which
means that the integral
overall space of the absolute value
squared of the wave function
must equal 1. remembering that the
eigenfunction
psi is separable into a radial and an
angular part
we can then rewrite the normalization
integral in spherical coordinates and we
get an integral
over the radial variable and a double
integral
over the angular variables
all of which must equal one
as we discussed in the video on the
eigenfunctions of orbital angular
momentum
we'll use a convention by which the
normalization of psi
is typically divided into the separate
normalizations of the radial part
and of the angular part
in terms of the u function the
normalization of the radial part
simply becomes the integral over d r of
the absolute value squared of the u
function
the final idea that i want to discuss
actually covers a very important and
interesting concept that goes beyond
what we're discussing today and
permeates all of physics
the concept of an effective potential
we know that for a single particle of
mass m moving in one dimension
the hamiltonian in the position
representation can be written
as the sum of a kinetic energy term
and a potential energy term
let's now consider the radial equation
of a particle moving
in three dimensions
this was the latest expression that we
got for the radial equation in terms of
the u function
this equation has the form of an
eigenvalue equation for a hamiltonian
which i will call the radial hamiltonian
it is given
by the term in square brackets
we can now combine these two terms to
define a new function
v sub f and we can then
rewrite this radial hamiltonian like
this
if we now compare this latest expression
for the radial hamiltonian
with the one up here for a particle
moving in one d
we see that our radial hamiltonian looks
like that of a particle of mass m
moving in a one-dimensional potential vf
for this reason we call it an effective
potential
and this is also the reason for the
subscript eff
here to make the analogy complete with
the 1d case above
we need to remember that the radial
variable r cannot be negative
so you can think of this effective
potential as having an infinite wall
for negative r right so this is all very
neat
but why do we do it using the concept of
an effective potential means that we can
use
everything we already know about
particles moving in one dimension
to solve this new problem this is a
strategy that we use in many different
areas of physics
if we can rewrite a new problem in a
mathematical form
that parallels the mathematical form of
another problem that we have already
solved
then we can solve our new problem much
more easily because we can use
all the prior knowledge about the
problem that we have already solved
this is true not only for the maths but
actually also for the physics
if we can connect seemingly different
problems in this way
then this typically provides new
connections between different areas of
physics that bring out
fundamental connections that may not
always be
superficially apparent
but going back to our effective
potential let's see what it all means
in this particular example of a particle
moving in a three-dimensional central
potential
our real potential is v of r here
this extra term in the effective
potential comes from the original
kinetic energy term what happened is
that the original problem was a
three-dimensional problem
and we've reduced it to this one
variable problem in terms of
r only and in doing so some terms have
acquired a form
that no longer resembles the usual form
of a kinetic energy and quantum
mechanics
when we think in terms of effective
potentials we therefore forget
that this is part of the kinetic energy
because it's more convenient to think of
it
as an effective potential energy
conceptually we're trying to describe a
three-dimensional problem
using an effective motion in one
dimension and this
extra term encodes the effects of the
angular part
of that motion so let's draw a pair of
factors
on the horizontal axis we place the r
variable
and on the vertical axis we first place
the real potential
let's now pick an example of a central
potential and we can use the attractive
coulomb potential which is proportional
to -1 over r
we can schematically draw it right here
let's now add the effective potential to
the vertical axis
looking at the definition up here we see
that we actually have
a different defective potential for
every value of l
for l equals zero the effective
potential is equal to the real potential
and we can just add it to the diagram
for any l larger than 0 we end up with
the sum of the real potential and then a
term that goes like 1 over r
squared as one over r
squared increases faster than one over r
decreases
then the effective potential looks
something like this
for l equals one for larger l
we have the same asymptotic behavior and
the only difference is that the
proportionality constant associated with
the 1
over r squared term becomes larger
so the effective potentials will deviate
more from the real potential
for example for l equals 2 we would get
something
like this this discussion is actually
something that you may have already
encountered
in classical mechanics where central
potentials can also be described
in terms of effective one-dimensional
potentials
for the radial part of the problem if
this were a classical potential
then for the real attractive coulomb
potential
v of r then a particle would feel an
attractive force towards the origin
everywhere however for any of the
effective potentials with
l larger than zero we actually see that
close to the origin the potential has a
negative slope
so the force that a classical particle
would feel becomes repulsive
in this situation the effective
potential is usually called a
centrifugal potential
another term typically used to describe
this part
of the effective potential is the
angular momentum barrier
if we remember that the radial function
r vanishes for
l larger than zero this now rationalizes
that result
by showing that this angular momentum
barrier
pushes the wave function away from the
origin
i've used an attractive coulomb
potential for this example
but we would find a similar behavior if
we had used a different
central potential so feel free to try it
out
on your own
overall the eigenfunctions of the
hamiltonian describing
a central potential can be written in
terms of a radial part
and an angular part the angular is given
by spherical
harmonics which simultaneously obey the
eigenvalue equations of the square
orbital angular momentum
and the lz component of orbital angular
momentum
we solved these in the videos on orbital
angular momentum
and they are exactly the same for any
central potential
the radial function r obeys this
differential equation
called the radial equation
unlike the angular part this radial part
changes depending on the form of the
rail potential here
and you can find a few examples in the
videos that we've linked
in the description to actually solve the
radial equation
it is convenient to rewrite the radial
function
r in terms of a new function u
and this function u obeys this simpler
differential equation
subject to adding this boundary
condition to ensure
that we get valid solutions
we will leave it here today but check
out our other videos for examples of
specific radial equations and their
solution
now that we know what the radial
equation looks like we're ready to study
a lot of different systems for example
you can check out our videos on the
three-dimensional isotropic harmonic
oscillator or on our favorite system the
hydrogen atom
and as always if you liked this video
please subscribe